feedback processes evaluation cycles
up or out principle working in
consulting can be tough it can be a
challenge
and there is for sure lots of pressure
also attached to it
and a big part of that are the constant
evaluation processes
every half a year sometimes even every
quarter
you will get a formal evaluation where
your performance
is being assessed where you will be
looked at and people will ask themselves
where this consultant heinrich or
whatever your name is
how did this person perform welcome to
another coffee break here on my channel
firm learning
my name is heiner hinon from learning i
want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career and
today we're going to talk about the
evaluation processes for consultants
and specifically i will share with you
how consultants are evaluated
what are the criteria that are being
applied if your performance
as a consultant is assessed and of
course it's important to understand that
these processes always differ slightly
firm by firm but in my experience also
when talking to
other friends working in other firms i
just know that it really comes down
to three key criteria that pretty much
all firms are using
so in today's video i will explain to
you what these three criteria
are what you can do to be rated well to
be assessed well in these three criteria
and also to talk about how the
performance of a good consultant differs
from the performance of a great
consultant so what you can do to go from
good to great
let's start by talking about the first
of three key dimensions that are used by
most firms to evaluate your performance
as a consultant
and these are your analytical abilities
what does this exactly mean though what
is measured here this means how
good you are at structuring problems and
solving problems
and working with data getting insights
from data
this is all what's in here and
especially for junior consultants this
often means working in excel right so
crunching numbers
in excel working with spreadsheets
getting insights out of data
but then also your contribution in team
problem solving sessions so if you're
sitting together with your team
maybe your partner is flying in with
your project lead with other team
colleagues
you're debating a problem from your work
from the project how well
are you to contribute to that how much
of a value add
are you to solve the problems at hand
that the team is facing
all of this is part of your analytical
abilities and all of this will be
measured in this regard so let's now
talk about how a good consultant
distinguishes him or herself from a
great consultant
in regards to these analytical abilities
so a good consultant is doing well what
he or she is being told so you might sit
together with a project lead the project
lead provides you a data set
and the project need asks you to conduct
an analysis based on this data set
so a good consultant would do exactly
that would prepare a clean
nice analysis would crunch the numbers
get to a result
but the great consultant would go one
step further the great consultant in the
middle of the analysis might realize
that the actual question at hand cannot
really be answered by these
numbers that are included in the data
set this great consultant would realize
that probably he or she would need some
other data inputs to really get to a
great conclusion so instead of now just
doing just completing this analysis
because this
is what the project lee told him or
herself the great consultant would go
out
potentially talk to another client get
this data that would
actually be needed then integrate it in
the analysis
and then just prepare the good final
result that then really also answers the
question at hand
the second evaluation criterion i want
to talk about are your team abilities
so what exactly does this mean team
abilities well this is how well you
contribute
to the overall success of a team are you
just a lonely wolf just working for
yourself
or are you actually a team player also
supporting other people supporting the
team
your one question always is to what
extent you really contribute to a
positive and inclusive atmosphere in the
team room
sometimes things can be tough your team
might struggle with a difficult client
maybe you need to work late for several
days in a row
and all these things can really take a
toll on team morale
are you then the person who always
complains adds to all this negativity
draws everybody down or are you the
person who despite difficult
circumstances
is able to increase the team morale to
contribute to create
and add to an overall positive
atmosphere this is always a key question
that also i like to use when evaluating
teammates
on this criterion but then it's also
about other things how you communicate
how you work together with your
teammates
so if you get some tasks from your
project lead are you reliable
can you be trusted that you get that
done that you really will do your very
very best to complete the task as you've
been asked or maybe you see your
teammate is struggling with something
are you taking the time to sit together
with a teammate maybe it's a teammate
which is a bit more junior than you
maybe it's an intern
are you taking the time to help that
intern to develop that intern
all of these are qualities which are
looked at which are considered when
making this decision
so again let's talk about what
distinguishes a good consultant from a
great consultant when we talk about
these theme abilities
a good consultant in this regard is
reliable he or she would get all the
things done and then the project lead
us that consulted to do and if indeed
the project lead would ask that
consultant
to potentially also pick up some tasks
from another colleague even though these
tasks are not necessarily part
of your work stream that you're
responsible for then you would happily
do that as a good consultant the great
consultant would go one step
further so let's think back about the
situation where maybe things
are a bit tough team morale is down
things are a bit difficult at the moment
the great consultant would take
initiative would ask him or herself
what can i really do personally to
contribute to that and here one of the
things that this great consultant then
could do is to suggest to do a team
event
and this great consultant could then
even research potential things that
could be done
close to the office location could
organize a door
book it into the calendars make sure
that everybody is having a good time
these things are always great because of
course it's difficult to do this on top
of all your other duties
also for the project lead doing things
like that organizing things like that on
top of everything else can be quite a
burden so everybody will be super happy
if you're taking care of this and of
course if you do this proactively just
taking the initiative
organizing this this will always be
considered to be a great team player
just great contributing to the overall
team atmosphere
the third evaluation criterion are your
client abilities so how well
are you to work with and interact with
your clients and this can take all kinds
of forms
for sure your ability to lead client
meetings to lead interviews with clients
to communicate
things away to clients will play a role
here also often your abilities to create
written documents that are then
presented in front of clients that are
shown in front of clients
goes into that as well but here also
your overall ability to build a
trust-based relationship
but the extent to which the client
really wants to work with you because
the client sees you as a trusted advisor
with whom he or she would love to talk
to use you as a sparing's partner
get some feedback from you on ideas on
all kinds of topics that the client is
currently working on
and trust me as a project lead you
notice that
you notice if a client just randomly
walks into your team room
and wants to talk to some of your
consultants because the client really
enjoys talking to the person just would
love to get an opinion
on that person and here for sure a good
junior consultant would be able to build
a great working relationship with a
consultant
where you can in an effective way work
together exchange some ideas iterate on
some documents really work on an
end product together but the great
consultant would go one step
further so not only is this consulting
using the client to get some information
to get some data but the consultant
would really want to build a
relationship with a client the
relationship where both parties benefit
a relationship where potentially even
after the end of the project
both of you will stay in touch because
especially when you then get more and
more senior
these relationships are for sure
insanely important
because these relationships are the
starting position
of new projects of new client
discussions and then potentially
follow-on projects
might evolve on in the future and here
one tip that i got from a project lead i
worked with in one of my first projects
was that on
every single project you should try to
pick at least one person
at least one client with whom you really
enjoy working
and then try to build a friendship with
this client try to stay in contact
right to this client every six month or
so stay in contact
with this person just to build also your
professional network
because maybe this client at the time
when you work with this person
isn't even that senior isn't even that
important in the client organization but
in the same way that you progress
throughout your career
the same way often than clients are
progressing through their career as well
so a junior client who is junior today
maybe in three four five six seven years
once you are partner
is a pretty important pretty senior
client indeed and if you start building
your professional network like this
early on
chances are pretty high that besides all
the other benefits that you of course
also have by
gaining your valuable contact by
expanding your network chances are
higher
than this will really benefit you also
in the long term goal of potentially
acquiring new projects for your firm
i'd love to hear from you now what is
your experience with evaluation
processes so if you have any tips you'd
like to share just write a comment below
in the comment section
and as you know i do my very best to
answer every single comment that you
write
if you took any value out of this video
at all please hit the like button for
the youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel to
stay up to date on all my content i also
started to become more active on both
twitch and tick tock so check that out
as well there's a link to that in the
video description i'd
also like to give a shout out to all the
members of firm learning thanks so much
for your support
and if you want to continue your
learning journey i suggest you check out
the video on the up or out principle
which is very closely related to
everything we just discussed today so
we'll link it somewhere above here check
it out to learn more about this
my name is heinrich i'm the creator of
from learning i release new videos
every single week here on my channel so
see you again next saturday
good weekend to all of you and bye bye